i think just in your eyes
in your work there's a passion uh
that just is obvious and it's inspiring
it's contagious
what um if you were to give advice
to us a young person today in the crazy
chaos that we live today about life
about how to how to uh
how to discover their passion is there
some words
that you could give first of all i would
say the main things for a young person
is stay adaptable and and this is back
to this issue of why
covet is useful for us because it forces
us off our tracks
the the fact is the jobs that will exist
20 years from now we don't even have
names for we can't even imagine the jobs
that
exist and so when young people that i
know go into college and they say hey
what should i major in and so on
college is and should be less and less
vocational as in oh i'm going to learn
how to do this and then i'm going to do
that the rest of my career
the world just isn't that way anymore
with the the exponential speed of things
so the important thing is learning how
to learn learning how to be
live wired and adaptable that's really
key and what i tell what i advise young
people when i talk to them
is you know what you digest
that that's what gives you the raw
storehouse of things that you can remix
and and be creative with
and so eat broadly and widely
and and obviously this is the wonderful
thing about the internet world we live
in now is you kind of can't help it
you're constantly whoa
you know you go down some mole hole of
wikipedia and you think oh i didn't even
realize that it was a thing i didn't
know that existed
and so embrace that embrace that yeah
exactly
and what i tell people is just always do
a gut check about okay i'm reading this
paper and yeah i think that
but this paper wow that really i
really cared about that so i i tell them
just keep a real
sniff out for that and when you find
those things keep going down those paths
yeah don't be afraid i mean that that's
one of the the challenges and the
downsides of having so many beautiful
options
is that uh sometimes people are a little
bit afraid to really commit
but that that's very true if there's
something that just sparks
yeah your interest and passion just run
with it i mean that's
it goes back to the hyderabad quote
i mean we only get this one life and
that trajectory
it does it doesn't last forever so just
if something sparks your imagination
your passion is wrong with it yeah
exactly i don't think there's a more
uh beautiful way to end the day it's a
huge honor to finally
meet you your work is inspiring so many
people i've talked to so many people who
are passionate about
neuroscience about the brain even
outside that uh
read your book so i hope uh i hope you
keep doing
so i i think you're already there with
carl sagan i hope you continue growing
um yeah it was honor talking today
thanks so much great you too lex
wonderful
you